in honor of Mother's Day let's think of
the children specifically is the GOP in
danger of losing millenials forever
absolutely not
we will mine the hidden calf FA in the
latest poll numbers and explain why the
kids are alright well some kids are
alright actually the overgrown adult
kids by whom I mean Democrat politicians
they continue to make fools of
themselves that'll be fun too then on
this day in history Lewis and Clark
depart for their journey across the
continent joined by an Indian mother and
gold dollar icon Sacagawea manifest
destiny and more I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh this is a big topic this is a big one
there's some disagreement on the right
about this now whether we're about to
lose millenials forever or if as I think
everything is just going great for the
GOP on young voters or is about to go
right before we get to that before we
talk about how much we're thriving right
now in politics I want to thank a
wonderful sponsor of ours thrive market
I love thrive market thrive market calm
slash michael mi CH AE L thrive market
is so good all I do for you people is I
give you food and drinks and I just give
I give I give so much to you thrive
market is really good it's a
revolutionary online marketplace on a
mission to make healthy living easy and
affordable for everyone if it were up to
me of our left to my own devices I'd
probably be lying in a gutter drinking
milkshakes made of like queso and just
froth you know just sort of dirt and
froth fortunately I get thrive market
and these guys are so so good
you can shop for thousands of the best
selling non-gmo foods and natural
products always at twenty-five to fifty
percent below traditional retail prices
now when you go to stores these things
are very expensive you go to thrive
you're gonna get a much lower price
before in the old days you know I was
basically only eating GMO I was just
eating pure GMOs I remember that's day
you don't want that that doesn't feel
good for you so it's really really good
you get snacks vitamin supplements
personal care products eco friendly
cleaning supplies safe non-toxic beauty
products just everything you need for
your kitchen you get it right to your
door filter the catalog by your values
and dietary preferences are you paleo
gluten-free vegan kosher ketogenic I'm
all of those you can shop for 90 plus
values including non-gmo sustainably
farmed Fairtrade certified bpa free on
and on and on because thrive market does
the homework for you yeah really really
good more than 70% of thrive market
catalog cannot be found on Amazon I look
just even the olive oil they have this
superb olive oil on the site being a
Kevon Italian myself I use a lot of
olive oil when I cook I use about three
bottles per dish and I love there
it is my favorite olive oil it's the
largest retailer in the country that
sells exclusively non-gmo groceries let
me give you $60 of free organic
groceries plus free shipping and a
30-day trial 60 bucks of free really
good food you would be very foolish not
to do this
users will get $20 off their first three
orders of $49 or more plus free shipping
and most most shoppers spend more than
49 on the website anyway there's just
too much good stuff there go to thrive
market dot-com slash Michael mi CH AE L
to get your instance $60 off free
groceries thrive th RI ve market.com
slash michael mi CH AE l and get $60 of
free groceries do it now okay
or the kids all right are the kids all
right are those darn kids ruining our
country or are the kids alright we're
talking about Millennials by the way for
those who are unfamiliar with them
I maybe have read about them a little
bit here's just a short informational
video produced about Millennials by the
United States Census here it is between
1982 and 2004 anyone who thinks loving
sriracha or Austin Texas counts as a
personality
Millennials crave things like instant
gratification authentic experiences and
for some reason we haven't figured out
yet improv comedy here's one millennial
who has a parakeet with nine million
followers on snapchat
here's another who's single-handedly
started the hashtags that canceled 12
Network TV shows she found offensive and
now I'm told she identifies as a man so
I'm being fired hello I'm your new
announcer and actually he was just about
done thank you and good day that's
incredible documentary footage produced
by the federal government or by Family
Guy I know it's one one one of those two
things there's two real though it could
be a documentary Millennials they are
the much-maligned group of people that
are my age and they're much maligned
mostly rightly so they mostly deserve
the scorn that they get but I come
bearing good news so Ben wrote a piece
at the Weekly Standard last week and it
was observing the leftward trend of
Millennials were rad
how the Millennials find themselves
politically on the left and that's true
I don't I don't disagree with that part
but as is sometimes the case Ben is a
little more pessimistic about the future
you know is not and I am like just
shooting off khofifah pistols I'm so
excited because I think the Millennials
are making the correct and the
generation after the Millennials the
younger generation are poised to move to
the right so Ben observes in his piece
that the Millennials have stayed on the
left they haven't moved
they haven't shifted radically to the
right they've become less religious they
support a lot of gay stuff and pot those
are two really big issues for them and
his piece cites this survey that came
out in January that 82 percent of
Republican voters between the ages of 18
and 24 want President Trump to be
primary Dinh 2020 not necessarily that
they want him to lose a primary but they
want him to be prime primary so that's a
terrifying figure isn't it 82% what does
that mean well it is worth pointing out
this was a survey from five months ago
that was before the North Korea deal the
North Korea diplomacy before the
hostages got released before the Iran
deal before the economy has continued to
explode before the kanye awakening which
has moved some numbers also this is just
one random SurveyMonkey survey which did
not release its methodology so forgive
me if I'm a little skeptical of it also
in the Weekly Standard last week another
friend of the show Kristen Soltis
Anderson wrote a similar piece also in
The Weekly Standard it points out that
we reacted very harshly to pajama boy
remember that guy dear this is during
the Obama 2012 campaign and it was that
guy who basically just looked like me he
was wearing these little glasses but he
had on a onesie pajama outfit and he was
holding hot cocoa and he said make sure
to talk about health insurance he you
know and it was it's just a perfect
picture of this sort of pathetic
millennial generation but as Kristen
says that we reacted too harshly we've
keep too much scorn on Millennials and
Republicans need to chase them or we're
gonna lose them forever or something I
don't see any of that
I don't really buy that picture at all I
see a much much rosier picture
Kristen writes in her article quote
Ronald Reagan was able to win an
enormous share of the youth
for his re-election campaign in the
1980s and as recently as the election
between George Bush and John Kerry young
voters were still somewhat narrowly
divided between the two political
parties it is only in the last decade
that a new and dramatic right-left old
young divide has emerged so you've got
to listen to the wording carefully we
can just run through really quickly in
the last since 1980 how the young voter
breakdown 18 to 21 or in some cases 18
to 29 when that those data were not
available how the young voters broke
Republican for versus Democrat in 1980
Ronald Reagan versus Jimmy Carter it was
44 for the Republican 45 for the
Democrat that's among young voters 1984
the numbers changed dramatically 61 for
Reagan 39 for his opponent Walter
Mondale that is a 40 percentage surge a
40 percent surge is only however many
percentage points but a 40 percent surge
from that 44 percent for Reagan in 1980
really big why did that happen we'll get
to that in a second 1988 George Bush
versus Michael Dukakis 53% of young
voters went for Bush 47 for Dukakis
pretty close you know he's still riding
Reagan's coattails 1992 George Bush and
Bill Clinton here is where the Democrats
broke away with the youth vote in part
because the economy wasn't doing you
know that wasn't doing great and it was
the focus of the campaign also Bill
Clinton was young very charismatic
George Bush Senior not quite as
charismatic so that election was 33 to
46 Clinton had a big lead among young
voters then Bill Clinton and Bob Dole
that lead remained it actually expanded
Clinton got 55% - Bob Dole's 35 percent
of the young voters vote mm it was
evenly split because Al Gore is like the
worst candidate in history says 47 47
2004 John Kerry walked away with it
again 56% of the young voters went for
John Kerry just 43 percent for George
Bush then comes Obama Obama just
destroys it he just obliterates it 66
percent of young voters for Barack Obama
32% for John McCain that trend maintains
ringg Mitt Romney in 2012 so that was 60
for Barack Obama 37 for Mitt Romney and
Donald Trump now if these are to be
believed that the Millennials are moving
further and further away you would
expect Donald Trump to do even worse
among Millennials right wrong that's not
what happened it was still a pretty wide
gap but he closed the gap significantly
Hillary only got 55 percent of voters 18
to 29 Donald Trump got 36 percent so he
basically maintained the Mitt Romney
amount he got more than John McCain did
and he was able to siphon off some
support from Democrats Donald Trump did
better among Millennials relative to his
opponent than either John McCain or Mitt
Romney which shows that this trend is
not inexorable it's not constantly
moving to the left something else is
going on Donald Trump also did better
among Hispanics relative to his opponent
than Mitt Romney why do I bring that up
this is an important figure in the
millennial story so it's not that Donald
Trump did very well among Hispanics but
he did relatively better than Mitt
Romney did a lot of this is not so much
a generational question as it is an
immigration question so it since 1980
since that Reagan election that we're
all talking about the Hispanic
population in America has nearly tripled
it's increased by 2.7 times now that
population which has exploded is also
extremely young so 60% of those Hispanic
immigrants are Millennials or younger
so this huge exploding demographic
seriously skews the Millennial vote also
worth noting that even up to the third
generation Hispanic immigrants to
America over overwhelmingly identify
with Democrats but they're between three
times as likely an eight point seven
five times as likely to identify with
Democrats so this is an overwhelming
electoral advantage for Democrats even
so Donald Trump did relatively well
among that major immigrant group and
that's reflected in part in the
Millennial statistic okay so what's
going on this gets back to Ronald Reagan
between 1980 and 1984 we saw a 39% surge
in young voter support for Ronald Reagan
why is that it's because successful
presidencies shape public opinion this
presidency so far whatever you think of
the tweets whatever you think of the
stupid media headlines it's been very
successful thus far it has been very
successful Donald Trump's approval
rating has been consistently higher than
Barack Obama's for a long time now at
their relative points in the presidency
you look day for day Barack Obama on
this day in his presidency eight years
ago Donald Trump is consistently doing
as well or higher the unemployment rate
right now in the United States across
the entire country is it a 44 year low
how about black unemployment is the line
they always use what the Democrats
always use they say well it's only
helping the rich white men and it's not
helping right now black unemployment is
at an all-time low you know there is
it's not at a forty four year low it's
at an all-time low it's the lowest ever
recorded how about on issues like civil
rights the NRA right now there was this
huge media onslaught of David hog and
the kids in Florida and all of it was
being funded by Hollywood in New York
there's huge onslaught to take away our
Second Amendment rights
right now the NRA is getting more
donations than practically ever before
they are getting their donations by the
truckload how about in just the two
parties the Republican National
Committee of the Democrat National
Committee the RNC right now has 40
million dollars more in cash than the
Democrats have that is a huge disparity
why is that in part Democrats have no
message what are they going to run on
what on earth could they run on dick
morris who is a republican strategist
but he also advised President Clinton he
says that there is no blue wave coming
that there is a red wave coming and that
red wave is gonna be red because of the
Democrat blood in the water he said this
is not what we think
and by the way lest you think that I'm
just putting a positive spin on this
it's just hopeful thinking I just blew
too many lines of Caffe before the show
and I'm overdosing on it that's not the
case well the other numbers bear this
out there was a recent poll I think it's
just out today from Reuters maybe it was
that last week writers left-leaning
outlet it shows that Millennials are
leaving the Democrat Party in droves so
they're leaving the Democrats where are
they going a new poll from morning
consult that's another left-leaning
outlet it shows that the Democrats are
in trouble in November in the midterm
elections that poll shows the Democrats
could lose up to nine seats in the
Senate
that would be colossal because all of
history tells us that Republicans should
lose the midterms Republicans should
lose the house maybe lose the Senate
they should just lose that's just what
happens when you have a one party
controlling the White House and yet
that's not what we're seeing possibly
bear out if we were able to pick up
seats in the Senate if we were able to
hold the line in the house that would be
colossal that would be a mandate to
govern there is a new poll out today by
Zogby analytics also not a right wing
analysis firm which says that that blue
wave that they'd all been promising us
remember it's coming get ready here
comes a blue wave that it's collapsing
that trust in Democrats is collapsing
nationally and here's the kicker folks
because support for Democrats nationally
has decreased by four percent but it's
been especially pronounced that that
collapse has been especially pronounced
among Millennials and racial minorities
those very people that we're supposed to
be afraid that we're losing forever they
are fleeing the Democrats Democrats lost
14% of their support among Millennials
and 20% of their support among black
Americans since January just the last
five months and who knows what those
numbers look like more recently as we've
had these extraordinary foreign policy
accomplishments great economic news and
this cultural cracking where you see
Kanye West's biggest pop star in the
entire country maybe in the world saying
yeah I like Trump he's my boy I really
like him he's my he's my brother I love
him what happens then what happens when
you have even chance the rapper who
doesn't like Donald Trump but he's a
very popular entertainer saying you know
black people don't have to vote for
Democrats what happens that this is a
cracking of a narrative that has been
used to keep people in line for so so
long and that popular culture is
cracking so overall support for Trump is
or support for the Democrats rather is
down 4% nationally what does that mean
if you take out minority voters and you
take out the Millennials that means that
the Democrat stalwarts the Democrat
diehards are decrepit old white hippies
and of course that's the case we see
that with a Larry Clinton we obviously
see with Bernie Sanders Bernie Sanders
is 485 years old right now I
you know he who else do they have what
else do they have that is there but
these are the guys they nominate who do
they run in 2016
Joe Biden Hillary Clinton Bernie Sanders
you know just the oldest most boring
white people ever that's not the
narrative that the mainstream media is
portraying but that's what we're seeing
reflected in polling that's what we're
seeing with our own eyes you know you
can believe your lyin eyes sometimes
conservatives try to be pessimistic
that's just sort of in our nature
sometimes I think because and it's not
really a pessimism but that is the
tendency what it really is is saying
this is a fallen world some things
things get better sometimes things get
worse and there is that old get off my
lawn everything's terrible kids these
days you know that attitude I don't buy
it I think the kids are all right I
think they're doing really good
Millennials grew up in the shadow of
george w bush's presidency and i i like
george w bush I support that presidency
but the mainstream media was able to
successfully portray it is absolutely
terrible with very little pushback they
the the White House the Bush White House
didn't want to fight back quite a
difference with Donald Trump he fights
back on every little syllable they utter
but they were able to paint it that way
and of course at the end of the Bush
presidency we had a financial crisis and
so when Millennials think about the Bush
years and the Republican Party they
think of economic collapse and they
think of the ridiculous narrative
painted by the mainstream media which is
demonstrably untrue the lies that they
spread about Bush with regard to war
with regard to domestic policy with
regard to social policy but that doesn't
matter because that's what that's all
the people remember now we're seeing huh
maybe that narrative isn't true you know
the Millennials grew up with Barack
Obama the mainstream media depicted him
as a god he depicted himself as a god he
said I'm gonna part the Seas the oceans
are going to come if you elect me and
everyone else played along on the world
stage they gave him a Nobel Peace Prize
for absolutely no reason so this is the
image that they've been brought up in
and they don't have a long historical
memory now the the Millennials are
getting their first taste of economic
prosperity because they were told oh
unemployment 2% or less economic growth
that's the new normal
get used to it that's so that's what
they thought now they're saying oh
well we're blasting past three percent
economic growth things are going well
record low unemployment ooh oh I guess
there is a different way me me maybe
that mainstream media maybe those those
guys are liars
maybe the narrative that they've been
telling me isn't true oh I can see that
it's not true because Donald Trump is
using his gigantic platform just on
Twitter which is bigger than the New
York Times platform to point out all the
times that they lie that is great my
take on the kids these days it is cool
man Keep Calm and Kofi fake now I should
I should clarify that because the kids
the actual kids you know people
teenagers up through their 20s they're
doing all right I'm pretty pleased with
them the adult kids the overgrown
buffoonish children who are Democrat
politicians those guys aren't doing that
well
so here's more evidence that the
Democrats have absolutely nothing this
election cycle here is Pat Davis
Democrat running for Congress in New
Mexico's first congressional district he
just released this ad the NRA their
pro-gun policies have resulted in dead
children dead mothers and dead fathers
I'm Pat Davis and I approve this message
because if Congress won't change our gun
laws we're changing Congress yeah yeah
you tell him Pat yeah by the way in the
ad that he ran it's not bleeped we had
to bleep it because you know we have
some self-respect
but he didn't bleep it then the first
word is the f-word and this is what you
get from Democrats now it's the same
thing is shout your abortion it's all
they've got is just profanity as though
our as their the popular culture weren't
profane right as though that's
subversive the whole culture is profane
the thing that's subversive now is to
use words that are nice and that aren't
you know swear words or something but
that's all they've got they say fu fu
that's not an argument fu is not a
political argument but what else do they
have everything's going so well they've
been so thoroughly discredited that all
they have is fu it's getting really
tedious even the left is admitting that
it's getting tedious by the way the the
Saturday Night Live cold opens that if
anyone still watches it no one still
watches it but we sometimes see the
clips on the news Saturday and I live
cold opens have
just been basically celebrity cameos and
the Alec Baldwin very subpar Donald
Trump impression that's all they've been
for the last like 50 years now at this
point check out the Mother's Day
cold-open that we saw this past weekend
do you like the sale right mom I do
except for all the political stuff we
get it all right thank you this is my
mom Sylvia mom do you ever think that
I'd be on SNL someday no awesome
remember I was in that production of The
Crucible in high school right yeah you
know the truth suppose a lot like
witch-hunt against president Chuck okay
don't let that let's go this is my mom
Cindy mom I love you because you always
give me the best advice thanks Luke
here's more enough with the Trump Joe's
mom I don't write those and why doesn't
us now ever talk about crooked Hillary
mom I'm so new here please do not do
this to me
so even SNL has to admit an SNL hates
this guy when Donald Trump won the
election they played this long piano
song this ballad it was they were
tearfully crying about Hillary losing
that wasn't a joke they actually did
that sincerely but even they have to
admit gosh maybe maybe we're going a
little crazy with this maybe people
don't love it when we just screech and
whine and yell about politics all the
time even Jimmy Kimmel speaking of
screeching and whining every single
night Jimmy Kimmel admitted this to
Deadline to the trades paper out here in
Hollywood he said that he's gonna steer
his jokes away from Trump jokes at an
upcoming show business industry event
because people have had enough they've
had enough of it Jerry Seinfeld doesn't
do Trump jokes of recently David
Letterman asked Seinfeld on his show he
said are you doing a lot of Trump jokes
and he said no I'm not interested I want
to tell jokes about raisins Ida because
Trump jokes they're easy they're cheap
and the people are sick of it another
overgrown child former future president
Hillary Clinton she has not gotten this
memo she didn't get it she is still
going around just whining about how she
lost the election how terrible
everything is here's a clip of her
recently in Australia doubles
and 'red is alive and well and it is
more difficult for women in public
positions well we'll talk about politics
but it's true in business it's true in
the media it's just true across the
board because there are expectations
about women's appearance that are deep
in our collective DNA so that people
feel free to comment either favorably or
unfavorably about hairstyles clothing
fashions and all the rest of it are you
kidding me
we are you that's your example you're
because you're whining making all these
excuses and saying I didn't win because
it wasn't fair
ba ba ba and the example you're using of
the double standard is that women have
their hair made fun of when you ran
against Donald Trump the the man who
possesses the most mocked hairdo in
maybe the history of the world everyone
since the 80s people have been making
jokes about Donald Trump's hair but
Hillary Clinton lives in this fantasy
world where everyone's against her
people only criticize women they only
make fun of women they only do what are
you talking about how about all of the
statues that went up in New York
showing Donald Trump's grotesque body
allegedly grotesque physique and all of
the cartoons and they're all no you're
just you're just first of all she's
isolated so everything is just in this
really tiny bubble for her but it's it's
not that it's unfair Hillary it's not
that other people don't get made fun of
and don't get put through the wringer
it's that they deal with it with any bit
of grace whatsoever which you have never
ever been able to do Hillary Clinton
went on by the way she said quote there
is still a very large proportion of the
population that is uneasy with women in
positions of leadership there is this
fear there is this anger even rage about
women's seeking power exercising power
okay so by the way when you look for the
video of this on the Internet
where they put this up the comments are
disabled that tells you all you need to
know when the comments are disabled it's
because the people putting up they know
they're like this probably isn't true
this is gonna get a big blowback isn't
it
so your first thought is just like a
good grief you know the second thought
is thank goodness this woman isn't
president because she hates her
countrymen and she's criticizing u.s.
foreign policy abroad she's criticizing
the Iran deal she's criticizing North
Korea it's a very unpatriotic and it's
her never-ending campaign this is the
never ending campaign but good I
actually I mean it's so disgusting it's
so undignified but keep going Hillary
keep going stay on TV I hope you do
people don't like this they don't let
you're turning people off from your own
party that's fine by me that is
absolutely fine by me there's a good
before we break I'll draw this analogy
they're trying to get Trump like their
truck they were trying to get Richard
Nixon they just ate him they're trying
to get him there was a good piece of
Bloomberg last week on Watergate and the
drawing the parallels they said you know
the Democrats won Watergate they won
this political battle we think of it as
a legal battle it was really a political
battle they won the political fight to
get Richard Nixon to resign and it's
because they had huge majorities in the
in the Senate and in the house and they
were able to force him to resign because
he couldn't survive an impeachment
hearing Steven calabria has a good piece
on how this relates to Donald Trump he
has it in the Wall Street Journal there
is a case Morrison versus Olson which is
famous both for its opinion and for its
dissent it was after the Watergate
debacle and Scalia dissented here this
was all about the constitutionality of
these independent counsels these special
counsels do they have too much power do
their so Scalia says this is
unconstitutional but even the majority
opinion of the court which has been
upheld in Edmund versus the US a free
enterprise fund versus the public
company oversight board it's been upheld
it said that the special counsel the
Independent Counsel is limited in scope
we can't have people here who can just
do whatever they want and have unchecked
unlimited power in the United States but
that's what we're getting in robert
motors investigation he's indicted all
sorts of people for alleged crimes that
have absolutely nothing to do with his
investigation which was supposed to be
about collusion with Russia during the
presidential election he's got way too
much power and this is only
certainly unconstitutional what it is an
example of his Democrats once again
trying to overturn a presidential
election they did it in 72 they're doing
it in 2016
Richard Nixon was elected in 1972 by a
landslide
he won 49 states he won almost the
entire country
he won 520 electoral votes to 17 for his
opponent Democrats couldn't deal with it
so a swamp creature policy analyst named
Daniel Ellsberg he stole classified
documents and he gave them to the New
York Times in the Washington Post that's
what he that's that was the big that's
how Watergate broke is a government
bureaucrat stole classified documents
and leaked it to the media which had
been trying to get Richard Nixon for
decades but that didn't turn out very
well for Democrats it didn't turn out
very well sure they got Nixon out that's
fine and then in 1980 six years later
they were able to elect Ronald Reagan
and we had basically conservative
governance for 28 years even the
presidency of Bill Clinton was
relatively quite conservative so let's
say you're you're a regular old American
who doesn't follow politics religiously
what are you seeing right now what are
you seeing you're seeing things working
just just look at the embassy in
Jerusalem you're seeing on the walls of
Jerusalem you're seeing thank you
president Trump god bless president
Trump that's what you're seeing you're
seeing the president the Prime Minister
of Israel Netanyahu
praising Trump for real leadership
you're seeing in Korea you're seeing
South Korea give Trump credit for peace
talks possible denuclearization you're
seeing a president actually fulfilling
his promises so what does the left do
the desperate left and the desperate
anti Trump right I think we're now all
that's left of the anti Trump right is
Mitt Romney basically what do they do
they criticize how he does all of the
successful things he does so Romney now
is criticizing the evangelical pastor
Robert Jeffress for us speaking at the
opening of the US Embassy in Jerusalem
he tweeted out this is Romney such a
religious bigot should not be giving the
prayer that opens the US Embassy in
Jerusalem and he's saying this because
this pastor called Mormonism and Islam
heresies which by the way is the
mainstream position of virtually every
Christian
and it's the traditional position in the
church so Ronnie says he's a religious
bigot religions are exclusive meant
first of all so yes religions say this
is the way to heaven this is their way
to have a relationship with God this is
the way and if you do this want religion
then you can't do this religion if this
religion is true then other religions
are not true that's just the nature of
religion religions are exclusive if they
can't all be true at once because they
make contradictory claims so by the way
if this pastor is a bigot then so is
Mitt Romney isn't he because his church
makes certain claims about religion and
who gets saved and how people get saved
Jenna Ellis pointed this out in the
Washington Examiner I think right now
people are looking at Romney they're
looking at these Trump critics and
they're saying seriously Donald Trump
has done what so many of his
predecessors promised to do and refused
to do Trump did it took real political
courage and you're knocking him because
the evangelical pastor who spoke at the
opening is an evangelical pastor Mitt
Romney invented Obamacare when he ran
for Senate he said I didn't support
Reagan Bush and I don't want to go back
to Reagan Bush he ran a terrible 2012
campaign he refused to take the fight to
the president he refused to fight back
at the mainstream media he tried to
swing the election for Hillary in 2016
you're the guy you're the guy
criticizing Donald Trump who's actually
doing something to advance the
conservative cause and make America
great again and improve the country and
I think people are on the Left right now
they're looking these lefties or looking
and they're wondering you know we had
eight years of a stagnant economy two
percent economic growth unemployment
underemployment now everything is doing
a lot better and these people on the
left and these Millennials people who
used to be on the left and then maybe
they're changing their mind a little
they're looking at their own politicians
and they're saying you told me Trump was
Hitler you told me he colluded with
Russia you promised me that Donald Trump
was Satan incarnate and the world would
go to hell in a handbasket if he were
elected and now everything's going great
and now the best that you guys have is a
porn star
with whom Donald Trump allegedly had a
consensual dalliance a dozen years ago
that's what you've got and I think there
is a shift going on culturally
successful presidencies shape public
piñon they are seismic events the models
are only true until they're not true the
models only work until something happens
and in politics things happen and in
this presidency the only thing that you
know is is Never Say Never
because it's a presidency of the
unexpected Millennials and young voters
have not seen success like this before
so you could say well if the last eight
years is any indication they're gonna
keep moving to the left until something
happens and you know what I think
something is happening you know what
else is happening we have to say goodbye
to Facebook and YouTube do you hear that
do you hear that it that is like bells
chiming birds singing because it is
almost time for our next episode of the
conversation featuring me little old me
Michael Knowles on Tuesday when is that
is that tomorrow that's tomorrow May
15th at 5:30 Eastern 2:30 Pacific I will
be taking all of your questions and
easing your anxiety by answering you
guys live on air every query that has
burned in your hearts will be resolved
best of all it is an extra hour-long
dose of little old me what else could
you ask for that's pretty good plus
Alicia crafts will be there too which
will be very nice this month's episode
will stream live on The Daily wires
YouTube and Facebook pages it will be
free for everyone to watch but only
subscribers can ask the questions to ask
questions as a subscriber log in to our
website daily wire.com head over the
conversation page and watch the live
stream after that just start typing into
the daily wired chat box there I will
answer questions as they come in for an
entire hour once again subscribe to get
your questions answered by me little ole
me Michael Knowles on Tuesday May 15th
at 5:30 Eastern 2:30 Pacific and join
the conversation now you might notice I
sound a little stuffy today I think it's
because milk offa is a hell of a drug
sometimes it gets lodged up there it's
gonna impair my ability to speak but I
hopefully we're gonna be able to clear
that out by tomorrow so I'll be able to
do this just fine we have an excellent
this day in history a much misunderstood
part of American history that doesn't
really get covered right now we will
discuss it talking about the Lewis and
Clark expedition but you have to go to
daily wire comm what do you get you get
me you get the end reclaim ensure you
get the Ben Shapiro show you get to ask
questions in the mailbag you get the
conversation which I just told you about
hey hey you guys
Millennials and racial minorities
they'll probably just uniformly vote for
Democrats right right is that Ono the
polling shows that they're moving right
word oh no I can't drink this down fast
enough I can drink as though as the
polls come out more and more polls come
out more and more great news from the
Trump administration this is gonna
overflow
get your leftist ears tumblr before you
and your family drown we will be right
back with this day in history go to
daily wire calm
all right this day in history
I've clear I think I've cleared out a
little bit of the cough FA let's get to
this day in history on this day in
history we have stub a little bit of
time in 1804 Meriwether Lewis and
William Clark at the commission of
President Thomas Jefferson launched
their expedition to explore the
northwest American continent from the
Mississippi River to the Pacific Ocean I
don't know that people really study
Lewis and Clark anymore maybe but it's a
pretty crazy part of American history
this this happened in just one year
after the Louisiana Purchase so Thomas
Jefferson buys the Louisiana territory
that doubles the size of the United
States so we now have double the country
with him you know just a year has
changed the size of the country at this
point and Jefferson says to Lewis and
Clark okay we need you to explore this
unexplored continent and really claim a
little bit more land for America but go
see what you can find the Corps of
Discovery as it was called Lewis and
Clark's group of people that included 45
men and 33 of whom made it the whole
journey
some of them hopped off by choice or
circumstance along the way the the Lewis
and Clark expedition started up the
Missouri River in a 55 foot long keel
boat with two smaller boats six months
into the expedition they met a Toussaint
Charbonneau a French Canadian fur trader
and you know him better as the husband
of Sacagawea I really want to bring this
up because of Sacagawea you you might
remember if you've been around the last
20 years that's she's the woman on those
gold dollar coins and much has been made
of Sacagawea she was the indispensable
part of the voyage she was really the
one who led them we owe everything to
Sacagawea but she doesn't get the
respect she deserves second it was all
Sacagawea right so we'll get back to her
the Lewis and Clark expedition spent the
winter in North Dakota they crossed
through Montana they passed the Rapids
of Clearwater and Snake rivers in canoes
they finally reached the Columbia River
that took them to the Pacific Ocean they
made it there on November 8th 1805 they
finally made it all the way west these
were these two
guys were the first Europeans ever to
reach the Pacific by land this is a
monumental expedition it took two and a
half years they brought back a lot of
information about the land and they
brought back a u.s. claim to the Oregon
Territory but there's been a lot of
revisionism here so they say about Lewis
and Clark's westward expansion
they say that Sacagawea was the guide
now actual scholars of the expedition
such as Ella Clark and Margo Edmunds
they say that Sacagawea was not the
guide for the expedition this is
perfectly clear these were incredible
pioneers men these were incredible
navigators Lewis and Clark they would
have made it just fine Sacagawea did
assist a little bit she helped out with
certain trading ventures but she was not
central here Lewis and Clark also did
not consider her central Lewis and Clark
would variously called her soir and
savage along the journey so it wasn't
you know wasn't this disney version of
what she was doing it also gets to the
crazy idea that America did not intend
to realize itself westward so now we
look back at western expansion and the
way it's taught in schools is oh yes we
had the country and then they just kept
invading other lands and taking it and
they shouldn't have done it and we
didn't mean to do it it wasn't you know
this wasn't part of America there's this
idea now that the founders of the
country they actually really wanted to
keep America precisely the size that it
was that westward expansion that wasn't
part of the American project you know
Jefferson just got a good deal on the
Louisiana territory and they just kind
of happened but we didn't mean for it to
happen and so all expansionism is bad we
shouldn't do that we should keep to
ourselves we want to just isolate
ourselves from everywhere else in the
world
not true the entire American project is
a project of western expansion it began
because a bunch of people in the old
world decided to explore the new world
it began because Christopher Columbus
wanted to following his deep religious
convictions wanted to bring the glory of
God to a new land and also find some new
roots and get some gold for his own
civilization then obviously the pilgrims
made it to Plymouth because they were
realizing westward there
they were conquering and settling down
in a new world how about even in the
founding era George Washington made his
entire fortune precisely on western
expansion he made a zillion dollars in
roughly on the Ohio company which
surveyed land in Ohio made a lot of
money getting land for himself until
Donald Trump Washington was actually the
wealthiest president in US history he
died with an estate worth seven hundred
eighty thousand dollars now which
doesn't sound like a lot when you
translate that into today's dollars that
would be about fourteen and a half
million but that actually doesn't tell
the whole story because if you factor in
relative wealth so Washington's relative
wealth to his countrymen and the rest of
the world a unit of measure called the
prestige value of money then it actually
his wealth was around four hundred
twenty-nine million dollars it's pretty
good that's he made a lot of money going
westward during the French and Indian
War that they were able to recruit
soldiers by offering two hundred
thousand acres of frontier land for
those who joined fight for our country
you get to move west because that's the
way we're going Washington himself got
23,000 of those acres for himself in
West Virginia Jefferson was urging
westward expansion is as early at least
as 1786 this was the project this was
moving westward that's what the country
was meant to do now people will tell you
today on the right and the left
some of the isolationists on the right
and the lefties who say oh we took the
land from those Indians who took the
land from other Indians before them and
who took the land from other Indians
before there may forget that part they
say I was unjust was unjust acquisition
Robert Frost I think I may have read
this on the show before Robert Frost got
this exactly right in a poem that he
read it at Kennedy's inauguration frost
read the land was ours before we were
the lands she was our land more than a
hundred years before we were her people
she was ours in Massachusetts in
Virginia but we were England's still
Colonials possessing what we were what
we still were unpossessed by possessed
by what we now no more possessed
something we were withholding made us
weak until we found out that it was
ourselves we were withholding from our
land of living and forthwith found
salvation and surrender such as we were
we gave ourselves outright
the deed of gift was many deeds of war
to the land vaguely realizing westward
but still unstirred artless unenhanced
such as she was such as she would become
this is the American project bigger
grander greater expansive this is an
American project we're seeing hints of
that come back we're seeing this is the
line that Reagan used it's the line that
Trump used for that same reason make
America great again you don't need to be
small you don't need to keep to yourself
you know this is great a rising tide
lifts all ships and it's it can bring
seismic changes in politics and in
people's lives I think that's what we're
seeing here a very cough FA way to start
the week come back tomorrow we have a
really cool guest I was fangirling all
day when we pre taped this interview
really good guest in tomorrow I'm gonna
try to clear all the cafe out of my
nasal cavity in the meantime until then
until tomorrow I will see you and on the
conversation
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show soon
the Michael Knoll show is a daily wire
forward publishing production executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey supervising producer Mathis
Glover our technical producer is austin
stevens edited by alex zingara audio is
mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair and makeup
is by Joshua Avera copyright forward
publishing 2018